I'm CG Matter and in this video I'm
going to show you how to do edge erosion
and erosion on the surface. The
algorithm for edgeware is you take your
mesh and you find edges that are very
sharp in a sense. We are then going to
thicken them, vary the radius, remesh
just for safety, apply one more
distortion, and we're going to take the
original mesh and cut out the new one.
And that is edgewware. For the face
erosion, we are going to spawn points
all over this mesh. We're going to get
rid of some of them, remesh cloud using
SDFs, add a bit of distortion, and again
take our original and cut away this.
This video is brought to you by
Squarespace, but we are going to talk
about that later. So, for our starter
mesh, let's do something simple like a
cube, which can then be swapped later. I
need to isolate the sharp edges here,
which in this case is all the edges. So,
I'm going to take the edge angle node,
which can give me the angle of every
edge. I don't care about the sign, if
it's positive or negative. I just need
to know is this angle bigger than a
certain number. This will be in radians,
so it's not like 0 to 90°, it's 0 to
p<unk> over4. So, I'm just going to make
this a value like 6 for now. We are then
going to isolate these edges by doing a
separate geometry and let's isolate the
edges that fit this criteria. And then
you see there's still remaining faces.
So I am going to delete geometry all the
faces. So delete faces only edges or I
guess only faces. Now to check that this
is working, I'm going to take my cube
and add some divisions to it. So
something like 4x4. If I look at the
result, you can see it's only those
harsh edges. It doesn't care about the
ones in the middle. Okay. Now let's make
them solid in a sense. Blender 5.0 know
boasts about the tube node. I'm not I'm
not [__] with that. I mean, look look
at this. So, what I'm going to use
instead is if you go to my website
cgmatter.com, so cgmatter.com, you go to
free nodes, you can get all the nodes I
use for absolutely free. You don't need
to be a member. And then with that, I'm
going to use my tube node. That's going
to require that the input is a curve.
So, we're going to do a mesh to curve.
And boom. Let's see that in solid view.
We are going to decrease the radius,
fill the gaps, and now we've solidified
this. In a case like this, and this is
very important, these curves aren't
going to connect. And because we're
doing booleans, ideally with manifolds,
we want it to be one solid thing. I'm
also going to use my SDF remesh node
that just kind of voluminizes this. And
then increase the quality. Divide this
by 10. This is kind of like a resolution
slider. And you can see we got really
good geo here. Now, you can see this
isn't very detailed. It's going to work.
We can cut one thing from another, but I
want more variety. So, in this curved
tube node, you can see we can control
kind of the size of this. Let's use a
noise texture node to decide that
radius. Connect that into the radius.
And we got to make sure that, you know,
by default it's around 0.02. So I'm
going to map range to kind of constrain
this 0.01 to like 0.02. You're going to
see this doesn't like really do anything
like it changes it a little. This is
because our curves don't have any
geometry, right? There's one here, a
point here. There's nothing in between
to give it resolution. So finally, I'm
going to take this and I'm going to run
a reample curve for like 100 points or
something like that. Let's add even more
variety. This can go lower. This can go
a bit higher. And we want to bring up
the contrast. So point4 to 6. Now that
we have that, it's always a good idea to
consolidate. So I'm going to turn this
control G into a node group. The only
thing I would like to control is
probably the kind of maximum angle. And
this can be called our edge selector.
And then once we're happy with our
distortion, this can also be a node.
Noisy tube. Please don't call me that.
Lastly, we have our SDF remsh. If you
see it inflates it a little, you can use
this threshold slider over here, which
basically says how tight to the mesh
should you go. So instead of 01, let's
do O1. Finally, let's add a bit more
detail with my distort node. Again,
cgmatter.com. I'm going to take the
strength, bring it down a lot, maybe
bring up the scale and the detail, and
then finally, of course, bring this down
even more. So now, if we take a look, we
have our cube. We selected the edges. We
turned it into a mesh. We turned it into
an SDF that we distorted. And now I just
cut one from another because these are
both manifold. They're good meshes. Good
little mesh. Good little mesh. I'm going
to run this through a mesh boolean,
taking the difference between our
original and our distorted one. I would
highly recommend using the manifold
mode. And let's see what that looks
like. So now we have this nice edgeware
that if I go into noisy tube, add a
multiplier to the radius over here, set
this to multiply, make that a parameter,
now I can vary the radius on the fly.
Procedural erosion on the edges. Now the
key part of this is it works on any
mesh. Any mesh. If I take this cube and
I replace it with a cylinder like this,
you can see now it's eroded only the
sharp edges, not these ones over here.
So, if I was to take this angle and make
it like too small of a number, you're
going to see it kind of does this to
every single edge, which might be what
you want. I assume it isn't. So, I'm
going to get rid of that. In fact, I'm
going to get rid of the cylinder and use
a group input, which is going to let me
model my own thing. I can then take
this, I can insert, I can extrude, and
on the fly, it's going to add that
erosion. Let's take this, do a vertex
bevel, just like that. And you have your
nice procedural erosion. Notice this
isn't going to work on very smooth
surfaces because our edge angle is quite
big. But if I was to bring this to zero,
you can see all of the sudden we have
erosion everywhere. And now I'm going to
move on to face erosion. But before you
do that, there's something you need to
know. This video is sponsored by
Squarespace. Best place to make a
website. In fact, you already heard me
talk about my website, cgmatter.com,
where I said you could get those free
nodes. And I have a member site that
Squarespace helps me make. So, this is
where I have all the exclusive stuff you
can download. Squarespace makes this
easy because they have their own
built-in payment platform that lets me
do this like membership thing. You can
see they also have an asset browser over
here where I can store all kinds of
assets, PGs, GIFs, files. If I'm to make
a new page, you can design whatever, but
I'm just going to add a blank section.
And then to that, I'm going to add a
text block. Put that over here. You are
going to notice that there's AI
integration natively. So, I can edit,
turn on this AI thing. Tell me about CG
Matter. Oh boy, what's it going to say?
CG Matter is a content creator and
educator. Damn right I am. If all this
sounds good to you, head over to
Squarespace, make a website, and when
you're ready to take that and launch,
use this link in the description to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain. And now, let's do face
erosion. The logic is going to be pretty
similar. We're just going to use
different things to cut away. So, I'm
going to take all of this, maybe make it
a nice node group. I can call this edge
erosion, which you would add parameters
for. Goodbye, edge erosion. You've
served us well. Like I said, for this
one, we need to spawn points on the
surface. I'm going to distribute points
on faces. Just make that a ridiculously
big number. I'm talking like 1500 or
something like that. And this will
dictate where our erosion is going to
be. I don't want that everywhere. So,
I'm going to delete geometry. Where am I
going to do that, you ask? Well, I'm
going to use a noise texture. Turn off
normalize so that this is positive or
negative. Delete or don't delete.
Connect that here. And now, when we play
with this, you can get rid of points in
different areas. In fact, we can bias
this by adding or subtracting something.
So, now you can see we're getting rid of
more or less. And then this needs to be
made into a mesh where we can cut one
thing from another. Well, the new 5.0, 0
at least as of recording. SDF nodes are
great for that. We're going to run a
points to SDF. This will make it a nice
volutric that you can kind of make the
impression of this. For the size of
this, like how far away from the points
are you looking? You could just plug in
the radius, which we can modify on the
fly. And we're going to take our voxil
or our resolution, kind of like the
inverse of it, like the size of a pixel.
And I am going to bring that down. Now,
we're going to clean this up in a
second, but for now, let's run a grid to
mesh. Turn it into an SDF grid. Turn it
back into a mesh. SDF is just a nice way
to go back and forth. And now you can
see our initial point cloud that we
called turned into a mesh. Take the
voxil, make it smaller. Now it's higher
resolution. And our radius, since we're
using that, let's make that smaller. So
set point radius. Divide that by like
three. Let's go a little higher so that
they're more connected. And now we're
going to take our original mesh, which
is the Taurus, and of course subtract
away this. The way we constructed this
is it should be a very nice SDF. Should
be. Connect this here. Connect this
here. And set this to manifold. And now
we preview that. And now we have very
nice face erosion that we can change on
the fly for erosion. Now, if you're
seeing kind of these hovering pieces,
right, that means that our point thing
kind of has holes in it, which is fine.
Like there's holes between the points.
Bring up the density. Now, the quality
of this erosion is going to be fully
dependent on our noise texture. So, if I
bring up the detail and then I bring up
the roughness, you can see now it looks
more cut out. That's going to be more
obvious as I take our SDF and bring up
the resolution. And it computes quite
fast and we haven't even baked it yet.
One thing you might notice is wherever
it's eroded, it kind of goes to the same
depth. And that makes sense because our
guiding points are all the exact same
radius. So, what if we took our like SDF
grid and the radius that's driving it,
we just vary it a little. I'm going to
take the radius. And we got to be
careful. We're going to multiply by a
random number. So, they're not all the
same. Maybe like.5 to 1.2. And now,
let's do a comparison. Before, after.
Before, after. To get this even higher
quality or more erosion. Here is what
I'm going to do. I'm going to take our
meshed point cloud. And this is
something that I can also distort. Run
my distort node inside of here. Make
that very tiny. More detail, more
roughness. And then even tinier. So
before, after. Now, if you look at our
erosion, you can see we're kind of
breaking up the pattern a little. For
even more detail before the distortion,
you just add a bit more geo with a
subdivide. And now you have more, you
know, detail. So let's get rid of this
Taurus and do something simple like a
cube. I'm seeing that the splotches are
a little too, I don't know, they're
splotchy. So I'm going to take the noise
texture. I'm going to bring down the
scale. bring down the detail a little.
And now you can see these chunks are a
lot bigger. And we can take that much
further. So we erode only a section of
it. And then we also run our edge
erosion. And that's that. But right now,
this looks pretty good to me. So I'm
going to take everything we did here.
Ctrl + G to make it a node group. So now
we have the whole dream team. And we now
want to delete some of the floaters.
Here's a little floater for example. The
way we isolate it even visually is we
say, ah, this little island over here
much smaller than the rest. In other
words, I can take the mesh island node
that will tell us what island does each
belong to. You can see that different
islands, so this one's purple and then
this one's yellow or whatever, um, have
different values. And then for each
island, what I can do is I can
accumulate on every island separately
the face area. So face area like that.
What does this mean? This means that the
total is going to give me the total
surface area of each island. And if that
total is very tiny under a threshold,
then we're going to delete it. Delete
geometry. If the total is less than,
we'll figure out what that number should
be. So, if I set this to one, that
already cleans it up perfectly while
preserving the whole thing. So, here
I've taken my mesh and absolutely
destroyed it. If I use my delete
geometry, you can see automatically
cleans it up actually surprisingly well.
So, I've been CG Matter. This has been
Edge Erosion and that's about it. Join
cgadder.com. I will see you next time.
Okay, bye.